welcome back tonight the fbi confirming
the russian cyber crime
gang called darkseid aptly named was
behind a cyber attack on a vital u.s
pipeline the colonial pipeline that
carries fuel from texas
to the northeast remains shut down at
this hour experts warn if that continues
it could push gas prices
sky high and widespread fuel shortages
around the country
joining us now republican arkansas
senator tom cotton senator cotton
how concerned are you about this
brian i'm very concerned i mean from two
different angles first off
no cyber gang in russia could conduct
this kind of attack against an american
piece of critical infrastructure
without the tacit or explicit knowledge
of vladimir putin's government
so first it shows that joe biden's weak
policy on russia
is having consequences for the american
people you know when you give away the
story to russia when you
extend a nuclear arms treaty that favors
russia over the united states you allow
russia to build a gas pipeline
to germany under the baltic sea when you
invite vladimir putin to a summit
despite all that you just embolden
vladimir putin
and his minions to launch these kind of
attacks in the us but the second it also
highlights just how bad joe biden's
energy policy is you know when you shut
down the keystone pipeline you take
federal lands out of production
for oil and gas of course you're going
to see higher prices at the gas pump
and if you have any kind of critical
infrastructure go down like this
that's only going to be higher energy
prices for the american people
absolutely incentive why not blink the
lights over there
we have better cyber technology than
they do so why not go show them you got
to find a way to solve this problem that
we have
right now or this going to happen to you
yeah brian this is again just an another
example of joe biden's weak policy
towards russia you know he calls
vladimir
putin a killer once and he acts like
he's a tough guy the democrats have been
beating their chest about russia for the
last four years
but as soon as joe biden got in office
they returned to their weak dovish roots
once again
they should immediately stop that
pipeline that russia is building towards
germany right and we should go on
offense that's what it takes to get
russia to pull in its horns
all right uh so senator this other big
story in the daily mail that not many
people are paying attention to but we
are
154 000 emails from hunter biden on that
laptop 103 text messages 2000 photos
one of those emails really struck a
chord because it talks about
a chinese spy chief of china who has an
assistant
who says i'm sending opposition research
to help joe biden's 2020 election bid
and wrote 40 personal messages but
that's a side note she also encouraged
him to draw from the company's account
before they were shut down wait a second
china helping president biden win
an election where have i heard that
before with a different country and a
different candidate
yeah brian it's astonishing what
continues to come out
about hunter biden one reason a lot of
the american people haven't heard about
this story is that
the blue media and big tech continues to
act like a phalanx of bodyguards
around joe biden remember what they did
last october when twitter and facebook
actively suppress stories about hunter
biden's shady overseas dealings
we need to get to the bottom of this we
need to understand exactly why joe biden
was involved with the so-called spy
chief to use his own words
um of china and also how he was able to
uh so easily
put what appears to be an agent of this
so-called spy chief
right in hunter biden's inner circle
right senator you were uh you were smart
enough not only to serve in the military
but before that
uh go to an ivy league education i was
going to but i didn't like the campus
uh it just wasn't didn't sing my name
but you uh
you want to tax the endowments of these
ivy league schools
it's in the zillions of dollars and it's
all tax free and it just sits there why
yeah brian i'm going to introduce
legislation tomorrow that i'm
introducing to the american people
tonight
on your show that's going to tax
endowments of the biggest
richest and frankly most liberal
universities in america
they have tens of billions of dollars
sitting in their endowment
they pay almost nothing in federal taxes
and they charge full freight to kids to
take
zoom classes and brian this is at a time
when they are also actively
indoctrinating students to hate america
to believe it's an oppressive
racist nation um if joe biden wants the
rich to pay their fair share
i think we should focus on these liberal
out of touch universities paying their
fair share we'll see if anybody on the
democratic side will put that together
until you get into the majority
it might be just a statement rather than
a bill that becomes a law
senator tom cotton thanks so much for
joining us tonight
thank you brian all right doug hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else